Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
Today is Thursday, which means it is clustered
day. We have teams from Adobe and Zapier
who have broken two clusters with forty eight
hours notice and will attempt to fix them
or at least fix each others in forty
minutes or less.
We'll see how they get on in just
a minute. Before that, I do have some
housekeeping and sponsors to say thank you to.
So thank you to Teleport. I've been using
Teleport Unclustered since almost the very beginning. It
is a fantastic tool that allows me to
share access to these clusters via GitHub single
sign on. Not only that, we use their
wonderful
web terminal editor
so that we can all type in the
same session. This makes pairing and debugging,
especially broken clusters a little bit easier, although
I won't be as bold enough to say
easy.
So thank you to Teleport. If you wanna
learn more, go to Rawkode.liveteleport.
That supports the show, keep the sponsor happy.
It means that we can keep doing Clustered
and giving away t shirts, which we'll be
doing in a minute.
I also wanna say thank you to Equinix
Metal. They have provided the hardware for every
single episode of Clustered, and these are not
small machines. I'm not using VMs with virtual
CPUs. I'm using big machines
with 48 plus
cores and a whole ton of RAM. Why?
Because it just makes it a little bit
more fun. So thank you to Equinix Metal.
You can also check out Equinix Medal by
using the quote Rawkode. This will get you
200 US dollars in credits. Learn more at
Rawkode.livemedal.
So thank you, Equinix.
We are also doing t shirt giveaways. Thank
you to our sponsors. So if you wanna
win a t shirt today, go to Rawkode.live/win.
You can tweet or follow accounts. These will
get you additional entries. I forgot to draw
the winners last week, so we're going to
do two winners from the last week's competition,
and we'll do two winners from today's competition
at the end of the episode. Don't let
me forget audience. This is on you now.
That's not a very nice thing to say
actually, is it? Like just blame the audience.
All right.
Let's introduce
our first team.
Hello. How are you all doing?
Hey. Hey.
Doing good. How about you? Yeah.
I did alright.
I I I always have, like, this existential
fear before Cluster, but then I settle into
it and have a bit more fun. How
do are you are you sharing the fear
with me a little bit here? I hope
so.
Little bit. Alright. Well, team z alright.
Team z, period, can you please introduce yourselves?
Tell us a little bit about you, and
then we'll we'll have some fun with our
customers.
Yeah. So I'm John Anderson.
I'm the engineering manager for the SRE team
at Zapier. So I mostly create Jira tickets,
but luckily, Adam wrote a CLI and Rust
for interacting with Jira. So I at least
stay sharp in the terminal.
Hey. I'm Joe,
and,
I used to perform live, in a Pink
Floyd tribute band in front of hundreds of
people, and somehow this is a little bit
more nerve wracking.
And, hey, I'm Adam. I'm an SRE on
the team, and, apparently, I'm famous for writing
some CLI that I guess I use a
little bit, but, yeah, it's nice.
Alright. Thank you all for sharing.
And I feel like I've just been told
that I've been pronouncing zapier man wrong my
entire life. So thank you for correcting me
live in front of our audience, John. Anyway
You will not be the first. That's probably
the biggest
probably I have. What if I don't even
know if Zapier or Zapier? Like, say it
again?
It rhymes with happier. Happier. That's how you
remember. Yeah. Zapier happier. Zapier happier. Alright.
Well, thank you all for the introductions. We're
all excited to see how you get on
with this cluster. So I am gonna share
my screen,
and we have forty two minutes. Those two
minutes are used as bonus minutes for me
to give you access to the cluster. So
I'm gonna come in and modify
your role.
You have not been able to see the
other cluster, which I love about Teleport.
And now you can.
So
I will open a session on our control
plan,
and this is gonna be Adobe.
Please feel free, don't feel free, please join
the session and give me an echo or
some command to let me know that you're
in it and then we'll get things kicked
off for today.
Alright. We got one.
I think John and I are sharing the
same session and not in the same one
as you guys are. Yeah. Please go to
active sessions.
Find this one, click the join button, and
then we'll all be I mean, the audience
can see everything that we type, which we
found to be quite important on clustered. So
If it's just me then, I only I'm
the only one that found the the correct
cluster.
Alright. It looks like you're all in. So
set up your cube config. Set up any
aliases that you need. Best of luck.
Oh, we got we got a special script.
We've got it. We're ready. We're ready to
go.
Cube control, g a q, etcd, helm. Oh,
yeah. Even setting up an alias. Alright.
Oh, yeah. So for this. Although I think
your tab completion
may have failed.
Yeah.
Okay. So let's see. So, yeah, so what
that did, if you look we didn't trust
Adobe.
So
we we have our own cube control now.
So let's check.
Perfect.
That's exactly what we want. Okay. It's fun.
Yeah.
Yeah. We we don't need you. You go
away since you're not ready.
That's interesting.
I would have expected that to Cartoon Creek
live.
So you're going Can we check
sorry. I was gonna say, can we check
the status of the like, all the pods,
like, especially cube system?
Yeah.
That's sorry. That's okay. Yeah. That's
That's fine.
So That's fine. We got a lot of
pending pods here. Yeah.
All those terminating, we're not gonna worry about
those.
Here. So let's see. Where are those? So
those are probably oh.
All on the worker. Yeah. Makes sense. Yeah.
Those are on the workers. So
okay. So let's see. Git node. So we
want to get rid of this, but that
won't actually go away right now. Right? So
so we're gonna have to figure out why
that won't drain.
So
can we Yeah. Do something simple like That's
good.
No. I'm not sure.
We should check
check API server logs for that one.
I'm gonna take a look at the logs
on the worker itself, see if anything interesting
is going on there. Alright. The API server
is out.
Unable to authenticate request.
Okay. So this token is Uh-oh.
The
one thing we didn't want him to do.
Invalid better token, service account token has been
invalidated.
Yep.
Well, we've not seen that before on clustered.
Yeah. So they
so we're gonna have to reissue that. Right?
Let's see.
Right.
I got a little jiggle problem. I can't
see half the screen.
Try typing reset. Hopefully, that'll
kick it back.
Okay.
Alright. So how do you guys wanna fix
the fact that we don't actually oh, well,
it's actually not.
Yeah.
So
the cube API server
can't talk to stuff right now.
Unable to authenticate the request and valid token.
So that means it's talking to and
it can't talk to it. Right? Oh, and
then there's also some sort of webhook. Check
the admission.cluster.live.
Yeah. I don't think there needs to be
a a admission webhook. That could be part
of it as well.
We should probably if we can
Oh, yeah. Let's see. We'll do get all.
What do we got in here? Yeah.
Alright. I'll put it into less so that
we can scroll. Let's see.
I don't see an admission webhook in there.
You get all doesn't return The dev ticket.
Yeah. That's Oh, yeah. Get
All is not all. Just to confuse you
more.
Yeah. There we go.
And not in it's not mutating. It was
admission.
Yeah. But Out whoops. Yeah. There we go.
There we go. That one. That one. Yeah.
Straight in with the delete.
Get out of here. Get out of here.
We don't want you.
Someone spent time handcrafting that, validating admission wiper
configuration. They just deleted it without even looking.
Some somebody. Come back.
Yeah. That's good. Yeah.
Alright.
So now we need,
yeah. So now we need to fix that
bear token issue. Right? Because we still have
that. Yes. Yes. Or was that the hook
that was giving us the problem? Could have
been. Check the yeah. Check double check the
API server logs.
Right. I've
there you go.
If your screen has given you a headache,
just resize your window by pixel. It it
does help.
Alright. So we still get the Yeah. Reset
issues. Yeah.
And I'm assuming that's talking to ETCD. Right?
So
but a bearer token. It shouldn't be using
Yep. Bearer oh, let's
see.
Yeah. Check. What is that? Endpoint.
Check if was up.
Is that what it is? Don't forget.
Health.
Health? Yeah.
And then I think
endpoint health. Yeah. Yep.
Okay. Okay.
Alright. There's also an endpoint status, which might
be useful depending on what you're trying to
check.
K.
That looks okay.
Yeah. Yeah. So I think we're good there.
That means it can authenticate. So what would
it be using a token for?
Shouldn't be using a token for anything.
Right. And we should probably check the
the API server.
There are other config files. Yeah?
So which log was giving you the Veritone?
Sorry.
The API server. So
the API server is making a request.
Or is this is this a request coming
to the API server?
Oh, yeah.
Probably.
I mean, it could be the worker. We
know the worker's not. Yeah. Check check yeah.
We can check that because if, like, the
rest of the control plane can access,
that's fine. We also might get more information
from the other control plane components.
Yeah.
Alright. I will open a session on Adobe
Worker one. Feel free to join that if
you wanna do some debugging over there.
Let's
open that. Alright.
So before I do that,
so
I've heard of this famous
Rawkode scheduler.
I think Infamous probably more than famous, but
yeah.
So that goes on the spec. Right? So
Yep.
Oh, check at the bottom as well. OneNote
had attained unreachable, so that's probably the network.
Which one did?
The worker, I assume. Unless it is it
could be that the controller is also unreachable,
but that
makes sense. Well
yeah.
So we probably want yeah. We need to
remove the taint off the master anyways if
we're gonna do that. Right? Yeah. If we
want anything scheduled there. If we can do
that now, that would
maybe get the network scheduling.
Probably, there's something else wrong with the network.
Oh, the worker is configured wrong. When I
did kubectl get pods, at least that was
pointed to local host eighty eighty.
There is no
authentication on the worker for you to be
able to run kubectl. Yeah. Right. That makes
sense. Alright.
Okay. So I just unpainted the
master.
That would be a look now.
So this is unpainted now.
Oh, sorry.
Oh,
it's still there.
Oh, so, yeah, I think we're gonna have
to fix that API server first because
when I
When I did that, that should've the server
doesn't have a node resource. Oh, whoops.
That's my bad. That's why it didn't work.
Okay. So that's untainted now.
Okay.
So we can there's no sorry. Go ahead.
Nope. Go ahead.
I know that on
the worker
general control
says there are no logs for Kubelet, so
that might be part of why it's not
there too.
Yeah. And it doesn't seem to be running
at all.
Yeah. Or interested in a worker?
Yeah. I'm gonna check. Yeah.
Where is it?
Says that I'm on never pull policy as
well.
Connected.
Okay.
So
there we go.
Okay. KubeLit is back on the worker.
Okay. So sorry, David. We're it sounds like
we're splitting up. I I don't know what
what you're watching. But I'm on a working
note right now looking at the journal control
logs for the Qbook, which doesn't look too
bad.
No. It doesn't, honestly. Better than I expected.
And I see we don't have a launch.
Back to the master.
Yeah. I cordoned the worker and drained it,
and so now I'm moving everything to the
control plane for now, at least. K.
The worker does say it's ready, though.
Oh, yeah. I think it was just card
and then triplet shut down. Right? It kinda
looks like maybe what happened there.
Are we still seeing tons of API server
errors or
oh, error image never pulled.
Yeah. But that's fine. So
Yeah.
Alright. So
that should make a new one. Right?
Hopefully.
Delete the bug?
Yep.
Still. Still.
Yeah.
Oh, there it is.
Well, there's a remove.
Out of this?
So it's just as a Yeah. See error.
Yeah. Yep. Let's
so that means my save didn't actually work.
Let's see. That's annoying. Oh, I am.
Yeah.
Yeah. Because I have the all oh, let's
see. Let's see. Pull. Oh, I think I
where is it? I think I edited the
wrong thing. Nope. Right there. Image. Yeah. It
should be there.
Alright.
So let's
woah.
Alright.
Alright. So let's see what this is actually
doing in here. Yeah.
It's not present with an policy. Okay. So
let's see.
There's a bunch of
I'm back on the worker. There's a bunch
of law I checked the Kubelet logs again.
There's a bunch of logs that it's struggling
to,
I think,
destroy network. So it doesn't seem it can't
create networks either.
I'm not very good with crack control. We're
still on a Docker control plane. So is
crack control pull supposed to be what I'm
doing?
CTR is the container d one, or or
wait. Yeah. There's
You can do it with both commands, I
believe.
Oh, yeah. You should do with the one
that has a
but how do I pull?
Yeah. Can get the list. You were right.
Great. It's awful. Okay.
So
that didn't seem like it was doing anything.
Let's do
phcr.io.
Alright. It's there. So it should be fallen.
And it appears to be GitHub, which is
good.
That better than we could have hoped for.
Let's see.
V one.
Alright. We did get we we just got
a lot of errors from on the worker.
And, yeah, they're what Adam said. It's a
bunch of Cilium failure of run network stuffs.
So I'm guessing Cilium is broken. Alright. So
yeah.
Well, I think those pods are just not
sorry. Yeah. Look at
we got one pending on the worker. Yeah.
That Cilium
Oh, but on the worker, don't care. I
cordoned the worker for now. So we only
care about the control plane right now.
Right.
So
yeah. So we have one that's there. That's
fine.
So what I'm thinking is there's some configuration
that's preventing us from pulling
that's
not the deploy. Like, the deploy is saying
pull.
So what else would be saying don't pull
images?
So if you do a
get deploy cluster dash o yaml and grep
for pull policy, it it does say always?
Yeah.
Oops. Wrong cluster.
It
does indeed.
Cool. Yeah. So it updated,
but then if you check here
it's
still erroring out there.
And so if I delete that,
it's gonna make a new one. Oh, actually,
it does. Yeah. So it does delete.
Oh. Oh, it's green.
Oh, that's not a problem.
Yeah. Alright. And that's definitely scheduled on the
control plan?
Oh, it's good to go.
Yep. Interesting.
Oh, but Postgres never moved. Well, let's just
That was bold.
Yeah. That one's bold.
What were they?
Could've started with the pod.
K. We should restore that.
Yeah. I'll I'll restart it. So but, like,
what I wanted to do is actually
that. Okay. There we go. That sounds fine.
That sounds fine.
Still terminated. That part, you you probably wanna
gonna have to for because it can't clean
up the it's it's Oh, yeah. Trying to
clean up the network. Right? So it's not
gonna do that. It's not gonna remove it
until network goes there
or the the network is fixed. So I
think we should probably fix figure out the
network problem.
We should check.
We've got different,
probably, config maps first.
Alright. Do you wanna run drive it for
a little bit?
Yeah. The audience is wanting to see the
container d config. They think something's
gonna be funny there. Container d config? Alright.
That's worth checking.
Get,
what am I looking for?
You would just drop config dump from container
d. It's like I think it's container d
config dump or cry control config dump. I
forget. Container d config dump problem link.
Yeah.
There there is no config.
Container
d config dump doesn't show anything
on the It says that con container d
slash config dot toml doesn't exist.
One way default, I guess.
Control plane? You're in your own session.
Oh, yeah. Sorry. I was letting you guys
do your thing while just poke around stuff.
Yeah. Yeah. Let me join up.
Alright. So if container d has no config,
it's unlikely
container d is responsible for the full policy,
which is the
makes it more interesting.
Yeah.
In fact, if we sorry. I'm just taking
over a little bit. But if we do
that, there's there's nothing interesting there at all.
At least nothing that I see.
Interesting.
So Not a good way. What else
yeah.
What else controls image pull policies
outside of
the image itself or outside the spec itself?
That's a good question. Like, maybe that cubelet
now because it'd be on Well, The oh,
cubelet is coordinating.
So it would at it might have logs.
If we if we terminate the pod, get
it to reschedule, and then check the recent
cubelet logs, we might see more information about
why it's choosing not to, possibly.
I find that interesting that this data and
the events show another pool.
The status also, like, if you did So
you described the the deploy. What if you
described the pod itself? Does it have a
pull policy?
Did we check that? That's a good question.
Oops. Sorry.
We can do it for now. Oh,
I'm lagging. Can someone type real quick? Put
pod in there for me. It.
Oh.
That's
there you go.
I think we need to add dash or
YAML to see if it's policy. Oh, no.
That's true.
Dash I on the oh, you did the
dash I. Before the Gitpod, not describe pod.
Oh, yeah. Oops. Thank
you.
Never. Oh. That's interesting. Getting mutated.
Yep.
But we got rid of all that. Did
we check mutating
go ahead. Yeah. Did we check all namespaces
for mutating admission controllers?
Or I believe you did. Yeah.
I I sure I remember a dash cap
at Lee on that, but it doesn't hurt
to double check things.
We're halfway through. Twenty minutes left.
Alright. So here, let's
Go ahead. Yeah.
So it it went away. What are the
other ones? Validating? Validating. And that was actually
what we had was the validating. Yeah. We
removed the validating.
And we don't have, like, or
anything in here? No?
That would also register a mutating webhook.
So it's unlikely to be kybernal.
Alright.
What else could be mutating our pod?
Controller manager would be responsible for creating did
we check the replica set?
The replica set never. That's a good idea.
Yeah.
Yeah. That's a good idea. So
I'm just gonna edit the pod as well
to see what happens. It's immutable. Rep rep
yeah. Replica sets are immutable. Yeah. It's immutable,
unfortunately. Yeah.
Nice try, though.
Well,
here. I no. No. I I will not
be fooled.
I I like that this is the multifaceted
break because you've got something modifying the spec
to never pull, and you're actually unable to
do a cry control pull as well. So
I think you can fix either one of
these and you might be alright. But Right.
I'm definitely curious about both breaks.
So look at this.
So so ready. So let's just describe.
K.
So
here, Adam, take over if you wanna, like,
get the rep with us at YAML and
look at what it's doing.
Do we have
There's that. Oh, look at that. It's for
bidding. Yeah. We got some resources.
Exceeded quota limits.
Oh, yes.
Sneaky.
Yeah.
Into
Dash dash all. On you go.
It's like Get get the spirit of things
here.
Alright.
That was
Check for limit ranges as well just to
be safe.
The obscure one that no one ever remembers,
then there you go.
Yeah.
Somebody did.
Oh, yeah. There we go. Gone.
Alright. Alright.
You will have to delete that pod to
kick start the replica set switchover.
That's a really cool effect. Like, because the
resource quota was there, we thought we were
getting a new pod, but we're actually getting
an old pod for an old replica set.
That was cool. Yep. Yeah. That was clever.
Yeah. That
was yeah. That's an effect you wanna expect.
Yep. Delete pod. Yeah.
Adobe.
Yeah. Hopefully, we are evil enough.
That that I didn't expect.
Oh.
Oh. We still have it.
Okay. There so there's three replica sets.
Can we get rid of two of them
so we can know which one we're, modifying?
I don't know how to do it.
Good work. Someone's
enthusiastic with the band hammer.
Oh, are we gonna get a container? We
are. It's pulling an image. Oh, it's pulling
an image. Nice.
Oh, buddy.
We still need to fix the Postgres one
too.
Running. We got that. Well,
k delete
Postgres SQL.
This is risky if it doesn't The pod?
Or Right.
So even though you reapplied
the stateful set, because it's a stateful set,
that postgres zero means it'll never spin up
a new one. Right?
Even though it's an old stateful So we
had to force it. Yeah. Like, graceful,
whatever. Yeah. Because it does the Yeah. Yeah.
Ordered rollout. I just wanna I wanna I
wanna check for
what
did I type wrong? Post
risk.
Is it
post guys go Oh, did it actually delete?
Oh, it might have deleted.
I didn't check afterwards. Yeah. It's gone. Okay.
There you go.
Describe that.
Forbidden.
We got more.
Alright. It's the same. It just needs
Yeah.
Any change will do. Yeah.
I'm just adding add an invitation.
Wait. Now I need to add it on
the pod. Right?
Oh, okay. This is easy.
Great pod. Yep.
Boom. Alright. Nope. Still over at zero.
Oh, yeah. Because I think you There you
go. There. Oh, there we go.
Curl local host 30000.
Let's see what it's doing now.
Check for network policies.
You,
Adobe.
As with everything else.
What's the point in knowing all the things
if you don't use all the things?
Eventually, we're gonna have an episode where someone
brings us stress that just deletes all webhooks,
all network policies.
K. Oh, get the service.
Check what endpoints we have.
Well, I should have
filtered then.
It's API server. We'll just Okay. I'm gonna
filter that.
Yeah. What do we got? We've got those.
Check
the endpoints too.
Okay. Yep.
Yeah. That looks good. So I'll do k
get e p. Let's see what e p's
we have. Right.
At the right one, it looks like that's
wait. Node name control plane. Yeah. That's right.
I mean, it's
no. Yeah.
It looks right.
Yeah. I tried it from a browser, and
I I don't think we can. Yeah.
Here. One second. I'll get back. Yeah. Go
ahead.
You're not in the pod.
Oh, what?
Yeah. So people don't know what's in the
port has changed. That is my fault
From a special eBPF episode we're doing at
KubeCon, I did change the port to a
privileged port for reasons.
So, yeah, this looks like it's look suspicious,
but it's okay.
But she's running,
but she's not responding.
It's p d. So why would she be
Are are we still on v one? We
should just change it to v two in
case
we did anything we is v two.
Is it v two? Okay.
Yeah. So is oh, is v two does
v two still have the old part port
number, or is it the new one?
They should both be compiled and pushed with
666 as a port.
Okay. Okay.
Dumb question. We're on v 2 now.
Okay. If that container doesn't have the port
exposed specifically,
can you still hit a new service? You
can. I believe they're just they're just hints.
Yep. Okay.
Yeah.
So, like, the problem right now is
this.
Right?
That's not actually listening to anything. Oh, that
should definitely work.
Is is Cilium still down?
Because
it could be messing with the routing. We
probably wanna get it at least try restarting
those pods and see if it comes back.
Oh, you were in the container when you
ran that curl. Yeah. That should work.
Yeah. That should've worked. Yeah. That should've
worked.
We have a problem in there. So we're
Just in case I am the I am
the the reason this is broken, can you
try curl an eighty eighty? I mean,
just in case. Okay. Yeah.
Makes sense. May maybe I'm the bad actor
in this one.
Oh, good. We'll multiple people to that for
us. Nope. So
the 666, it's in there. It's just hanging.
It could be trying to reach Postgres and
failing. Oh, you're not Right. Yeah. Exactly. It
still could be the network. So Yeah.
Okay.
What's the emissary and ambassador pods? You can
disregard those. Those are
a load balancer or an ingress controller that
we're not using. So
Okay. So even though they don't work, it's
It's alright. Yeah. You're all good.
Resolve conflict's good in there.
Alright. Adam, you can take over again. Yeah.
So Choco in the comments says, could it
be a silly of network policy?
I mean, it definitely could be, but the
local and local host, I'm sorry, the container
can't be affected by network policies because it
never touches the network. So
there's definitely something else.
It could be Unless it's trying to get
to Postgres. Yes. Like it's saying because it
can't get to Postgres. So I do set
the time out on a container of five
seconds. You should see a GIF come back
regardless,
which I don't think we were seeing.
Describe that part.
Oh.
Got ten minutes.
K.
Yeah. Let's see why Cilium's not coming up.
Zero nodes are available. Insufficient CPU. Okay. More
specs. So edit edit Cilium.
I mean, you can run an LS CPU.
There's definitely sufficient CPU in these machines.
Looking at h top is always quite funny.
Oh, good lord.
Not not a lot.
See, one
one didn't match the pod's nodes affinity
slash selector.
One node didn't match. Okay.
So edit the
oh, yeah. Edit the daemon set or deploy.
Well, you deploy the stateful set cleanly from
remote. Right?
Oh, is this Cilium? Yeah. You're okay. This
is Cilium, not Postgres. This is yeah. So
they modified Cilium.
A reminder that there are hints from Jake
in the chat.
So
K. Oh, there are hints. Oh, cat.
No. Don't do it. Don't do it.
We got ten minutes. This is Alright.
Well, let's set up the deploy first, and
then we'll look at them with the deploy.
Because we can see, you know, zero, two
nodes are available, one is a vision of
the CPU. They have confirmed that Cilium was
not modified. Fix the affinity.
Cilium was not modified. Okay. Well Thank you,
Jake. Then why is it failing to schedule?
Right. Oh, well, then that means keep schedule
or something like that. Mike forgot to see
if the hint fails, so you're hintless. But
they are in the chat and active if
you need hints.
Alright. Yeah. No worries.
So
let's see. Warning failed scheduling. Default schedule. Is
there multiple schedulers running?
Like, check just edit the daemon site and
check what its scheduler it's set to work
with.
But you you have a running Cilium on
the control plane. Right? Are you debugging the
worker or not Cilium?
Well, we called in the worker, so it
shouldn't be trying to put one over there.
Oh, it's a daemon set. So it would
still be scheduled even though the worker comes
out of phone. Yeah. So that's probably the
worker one. So we're probably okay. So let's
keep
let's figure out why
the pod can't talk to Postgres.
Right. Right.
I think network policies are the good So
build up.
CNPs.
Let's see.
So I forget what the Sicilian ones are.
CMP and CCMP.
That's the wide. Oh, look at that.
Adobe.
Now be careful with this delete because there's
two there.
Yeah. Don't delete it at fault until we
at least store it if you delete it.
So I assume we You may wanna look
at these. Is the one we like. Yeah.
We should let's let's look at these.
Yeah.
That one's You guys 85.
And then
let's look at the other one.
Yeah. Those are naughty. Seems really
five four three two. Yeah. I think we
get rid of both of those. Yep.
Sometimes it is it's better to check. Right?
Yep. What did I miss? You got a
clustered extra.
Oh, yeah. There we go.
Alright. Let's check.
CMPs? Pearl.
Oh, yes. CMPs. But you said that CMPs
and then Yeah.
Large ones with their policies, man. Like, they
they they're
really
see
Alright. Five minutes. I feel you're close. Well,
I have a guy and a delete in
there.
K. Yeah. Alright.
Okay. That's text. That says me too. Do
you want to put it in the browser?
Well
Can you open it in the browser for
us so we can see the video? And
try There's nothing listening there's nothing listening on
port 30,000
on the control plane.
Yeah. So I think there's still The node
port. Yeah. There's a node. Can we move
it back to the worker? Let's just revert
that. I think we're good from
but your current local host, it doesn't work.
Yeah. The end Yeah. It works. We're fixed,
but we'd like to see it in the
browser because the video's fine. Yeah.
But right. That's the point is the there's
no external IP for that for that clustered
node port, and there's no
it's not listening on port 30,000 on the
machine itself, so it's not gonna be able
to get out to the outside world.
I don't know why it's not.
Yeah. I can't get to it through a
browser.
Yeah. If you
So, like, it's
there is a node port, but if you
do
there's nothing there. Well, this is because, sadly,
I'm using eBPF.
Okay.
I
don't know. Adobe,
confirm whether this is you or accidental,
and we'll decide if we need to spend
time. Because I I mean, we've got the
Carl. I can see the v two asset
web m. I'm kind of happy. I would
love to see the dance, of course, but
I don't know if this is intended or
collateral
damage. So
I think this was you, David. Yeah. It
it it could very much be me.
But accidental.
Alright. Then we'll consider this fixed. Well done.
Well, well done.
And you had a whole three minutes to
spare.
Perfect.
Yeah.
Oh, nice work. Yeah. Zach is a little
smaller, so we don't use all those policies.
Yeah. There were there was a lot to
to debug there. The resource quotas and the
limit ranges were were were great because those
are so esoteric. Well, I mean, resource quotas
people probably do use. But limit ranges, I've
never seen them used in the wild, not
for a long time. So
alright. Good job. Well, thank you for joining
me. Feel free to
relax now
and join us on the YouTube video and
hopefully join us in the chat as we
invite team Adobe to come on and take
a look at your cluster. Oh, we're definitely
gonna be in there trolling them after that
one. Alright.
I'll let you get back to it. I'll
see you. Thank you very much and good
job. Yeah. Bye. Bye. Thank you.
Alright. I'll pop over here just now. Team
Adobe,
come and join us.
I will get the session ready.
Alrighty.
Let's see.
We got Mike,
Jacob,
Carlos.
I'll just give that one more minute.
So how's that? Are you enjoying watching someone
else work through your twister?
Oh, I thought they were gonna have it
in the first couple minutes for a second.
That's it. It never seems to go that
way.
But those were some some sneaky breaks.
And Yeah. The A lot of repetition network
policies, cluster wide network policies.
Just making sure your blast radius.
We thought for the validating webhook, we had
tested it so they'd have to go to
FCD for the admission controller.
But
I allowed them to just delete it. We
must have missed something.
So that that happens a lot as well.
I wouldn't worry about it. And then the
only three minutes to spare, so you definitely
kept them busy for that.
Yeah. Well,
thank you for joining us. We're now gonna
attempt another cluster, but if we could start
with some introductions, We'll start with you, Mike.
Just work our way around clockwise. Feel free
to say hello, share anything you want to
share, and then we'll we'll hand you over
to a cluster.
Yeah. I'm Mike Tujaran. I'm one of Adobe's
engineers on what we call our Ethos platform.
It's kind of our bespoke Kubernetes install that
runs the vast majority of Adobe's
containerized
workflows.
Adrian?
Hey, guys. I'm Adrian. I'm a cloud software
engineer at Adobe, and I'm also,
working together with Mike and Jacob
on the Adobe Kubernetes platform.
And I am very happy and hope
we'll get
to to
clean up the cluster today. Thank you. Thank
you.
Carlos?
Hey. I'm Carlos Sanchez. I work at Adobe
Experience Manager. We use the clusters,
the Kubernetes clusters that these guys build for
us. We
break them a lot, so maybe they got
some experience from this.
And now I'm scared about what's what's in
here for us.
Awesome. Thank you, Jacob.
K. I think I'm back.
You are back. You wanna say hello?
Hello. Hello.
Sorry. I was having some connectivity issues there.
But, yes, I am Jacob from Adobe. I'm
a lead engineer.
I've been working with Kubernetes for,
five years now. It's it's been a wild
ride. Have a lot of war stories, so
some fun stuff here.
Awesome. Thank you all for sharing. So I
am gonna pop over to the screen share,
give you access to your other cluster, and
then I'll give you a minute to get
set up.
You have to export your kube config, configure
any aliases, and you'll be good from there.
Awesome.
Alright.
And just a moment, this session to the
control plane will be open. From there, you
can use active sessions and join.
Oh, we have a wee hello as well
for you. Look at that.
Come and join the session. Let me know
that you're there and best of luck.
Alright. This is where I get nervous.
Alright. We got one in. Good. I'm gonna
join myself just in case we have a
Vim, which of course we always have Vim.
Alright. Four people. Awesome. Alright. Take it away.
Good luck.
Alright.
Jacob, you you still typing?
Yeah. So first things first. Let's go get
a script that, Zapier
team just used,
and let's go ahead and, you know, execute
that.
I
thought it was great that they just made
that a a public gist that I could
just go, you know, download and run. So,
you know, thank you. I really appreciate you
giving us our group CTL and our CTL
and a couple of things there.
And now that that's done, now let's go
add our own
and add a couple of things there and
source that.
Okay.
So now
let's see what we got.
There is no such thing as cheating on
clustered, although teams up here are trying to
claim otherwise.
There goes the admin.com.
Okay.
Well, let's go ahead and look at the
API server.
Nothing. Let's go look for a crew.
Your manager, had a controller manager, and a
scheduler.
K. Let's
see.
From here, let's let's take a look at
the manifest
and
see what we have.
Actually, let's first look at the Kubla to
see if that's actually running stuff.
Exited.
Exec.
K.
Permission denied.
Uh-oh.
Did you swap out the Kubelet?
I don't know. I guess it depends how
much you trust the timestamp on a binary
on a random Linux machine you've been given.
Right?
What is today's date? Yeah.
The date is correct. It was it was
correct. Yeah. It's the twenty eighth.
That
looks okay.
So problem spawning the Kubelet.
Let's see.
Thoughts here, team? What are you what are
you thinking?
Where should we go next?
What permissions
on the Kubelet are?
Yep. The config is not set.
That's right. Yeah. Where's the wee x?
Yes.
That one's simple. Let's see what journal is
doing now. We might need to restart it.
K.
True version. Oh, starting stuff.
That looks healthy.
K.
No. It's not found, so there might be
a problem with joining the cluster.
Let's go see now if
got an API server running
to scheduler controller manager.
Not seeing oh, the API's are. Yeah. K.
K. So let's see what happens.
Nothing.
Wonderful.
So let's go look at ports.
Hold on. Right
there. Do I go back to what you
were just looking at?
I can't scroll through.
Oh,
looks like there was a mismatch.
I mean, sorry, an IP mismatch between what
IP it was trying to connect to and
what the advertised
IP was for the API server.
K.
Should those IP should that IP be just
something different?
What is the
API server?
KubeConfig
settings.
For five,
should that be it, or should can we
just change it to local host?
You can. Yeah. Are you sure it's local
host? That'd be fine. So I show
the Not sure. It depends. The it should
match. The CT scan is 145.
It'd be 1454103121.
Yep. That's what it's set.
Right. So
let's take a look at what the API
server's advertising has.
I thought I saw a difference between the
two.
In the manufacturer's name?
Yeah.
Advertise address, it's the 10.network.
Should that be set to the public? I'm
not positive on that.
Yeah. Please also check the pre AL IP
of the masternode
just to make sure that is not a
misconfiguration
here.
So it probably should be advertising to the
the private IP or not. So if it's
advertising the private IP, the cube config should
probably be pointing to the
private IP as well.
K.
Let's see. I'm pulling up some other resources
right now. Mike, do you wanna you wanna
take over and start doing that?
Sure. I'm looking at something else really quick.
Scroll on me.
If you have a scrolling issues, you can
just drag
your window one pixel or type reset, and
it should help.
Type reset? Okay.
Alright.
I can type new API server.
You should be able to just copy that
address, which I'm assuming you're doing, enter the
admin.com.
Nope.
I find it interesting that you're getting the
correct error message, but you're also getting
something else on the output.
Oh, yeah.
So keep And even weirder that you used
their script to switch
out the cube control.
That's not the one the script downloaded, I
don't think.
Where's Espin.
It's our local Espin.
What one twenty three dot what do we
remember? Three. That's a month.
It's our local S. Ben.
Oops.
BUSR
local Ben
UCTL.
There we go. Now we're on a more
normal cube CTL.
So Kathy,
wrap API server.
API server is not
sorry, John.
Let's
look at what's
doing here real quick.
So that's there.
Cryo CTL.
Also not used to Cryo yet.
I think it's container
list.
No.
I see the list.
Cryo control PS, I think.
Yep.
Or pods list or yeah. Yes.
Yeah. So the UPS server still isn't running.
So
what's it like, Rawkode with the dash a?
Yeah. Let's check the static.
Yeah.
CD isn't running.
351.
Oh, I see something's getting in there. There
is
anything jump out at anybody real quick off
of that? If not
This the queue replic replicative manager, that's not
supposed to be there.
Yeah. That sounds fishy. And our SCD config
has peer URLs when these are set up
as single SCD instances.
So this is one thing. I'm just gonna
remove this this replica manager.
We need to Yeah. Oh, wow.
Damn. There's a whole bunch of.
Oh, man.
This happened.
I think someone pasted it into the terminal.
I just pasted the junk into the terminal.
Sorry. Did you look at the replica set
manager? What was it?
I did. Yes. It is the Rawkode
Academy cluster d. You can scroll up and
see it.
Just selecting the image for Rawkode Academy clustered.
So
apologies. I just pasted all that.
Okay.
So let's see.
What was this before? See if it clean
up any of those files that are excluded.
K.
Anyway, those
thing actions is the method. Folks are doing
the clean stuff. So I think the admin
one and the controller manager one are the
ones that I just created.
Now that looks
that looks similar to the case just above.
That's good.
Okay. So
let's see. So let's
so that CD isn't starting.
Right. I was wanting to think about the
containers, so we should probably take a look
at the logs.
Yeah. It's a good idea.
Let's see. Actually, three minutes ago.
Oh my goodness.
I
know what it is. I use iTerm, and
when I have it, something copies it.
Jeez. It's not doing it.
Sorry. Oh my goodness.
You're sabotaging yourselves now.
This is all just for everyone's enjoyment. You're
welcome. Okay.
Removing that.
Removing that. Oh my goodness. That's gonna trip
me up so many times. I just did
it again.
K.
Hey. Everything's going there. So your best bet
would just be to go to varlog containers
or pods, varlog pods, and you'll get the
logs from there. You can just tell them,
or you can just create control.
One. Expecting IP for.
K.
Is there a config file for SDU somewhere
that's not in the manifest folder?
Nope.
All inside of here?
Yep.
Wait. It's listing two peer URLs there.
There's only one in the FCD.
Hopefully.
I'm
not sure which one should be the right
one.
Where am I looking here? I'm in the
wrong place. You're in the right Up
five lines.
Mike, do you I'm really blanking on how
say this. Okay. So listen. Pure URL is
here.
Yeah. So it's got two IPs there where
there's only one control point node. So I
don't know what that 1337420
is.
Good
question.
So let's get rid of that.
Yeah.
Let's
remove that.
And then we gotta do this
client URL should only have one of them
as well.
So
local host
in this case. Now I'm guessing it's gonna
be
I think that that line's okay, to be
honest. To compare that against one.
K. Let's see
what happens here.
Not
showing it there. We might need to restart
the Kubelet in order to
you know,
just find out that would be good enough.
Oh, did somebody else talk to you?
Oh, sorry. I tried to reset my thing,
and it screwed it up. Sorry.
So let's restart the Kubelets
to force it to pick up its
manifest. Again, I know there's I know there's
a timer there, but
to
k.
Running two seconds ago.
Still running. That's good.
K. Much better. Running.
Serving traffic.
K.
Let's see.
Balance. We have API server. Hasn't restarted a
bunch of times.
Three eight forty four seconds ago.
See if not that one.
Let's see what's in here. Oh,
Let's
see.
Oh, okay.
We have our control plane up. Awesome.
See what's running on this.
So, Liam, operator,
necessary,
etcd,
clustered app,
miscrease.
Cool. All that is
looking okay.
That means we hit yeah. Yeah. And now
and now it looks like
we should also have the KubeCTL.
So what's interesting there is
Cilium operator, the one that's in crash loop
back off, has a public IP, not a
private IP
for one trying to get on to the
worker.
And
so does Cilium with 203 restarts.
So let's take a look at those.
Same operator.
Nope. Not.
Part of me just wants to rekick it
and let it come up again.
But oh, yep. Kubernetes service host is a
public IP address in the in the spec.
So
let's look at
the one that is running that doesn't have
that.
See what it's
oh,
dang it. It's highlighting here. Copy paste again?
Yeah.
Seriously.
Goodness gracious. Should I even be driving?
K. So let's run up here.
Kubernetes service host is a public IP address
for that pod too.
Interesting.
Let's take a look at previous, replica sets
to see what an older one looks like
and see if they
nicely left us the older ones or not.
No.
That's do we have?
So does run as a privileged
host namespace, so at least for network on
each node. So I think the public IP
and I'm I could be wrong. I think
that's a red heading.
Okay. Then let's look at
this container and see what's up.
Yeah. So the API server, remember, we have
running on the the private IP,
not the public IP.
Right.
Yeah. Let's check the deployment spec.
I saw some interesting environment variables in the
I'm for the
You're thinking
Yeah. Let's edit the deployment. Yeah. Or Yeah.
Do you wanna look through that?
No. Go ahead. I just opened it. But
I I think it's very obvious. There is
a a variable environment,
setting the API server to a public, IP
address.
Right. That might be the culprit here.
Yeah. Let's set that back to the the
private one.
Is it 127?
No. It would be the the 10 dot.
Do you remember that off the top of
your head? Well, if it's in the public
it it is in host network. That's the
same operator.
Right.
But it won't be able to get one
from the worker node. If it runs on
there, it won't be able to get to
local host.
Oh, you're right. K.
Then let's get
where it says
believe this is what it should be looking
at, the 109601.
That's where the Kubernetes API server should be.
Actually,
so then config wise
well, we can try it and see what
happens. So let's let's edit this.
Actually, by editing, are we going to cause
any problems with the pod that is currently
running?
Because we have one that is
actually, both are running right now.
Curious.
K. Maybe that's just maybe that's not something
we should pursue
at this point. Let's actually
I think it's probably now we have the
API server up, it's
probably a good time to go look for
errand policies.
Let's see what might those be.
Part of the list during the the
other call.
The little.
K. So let's get NetPole.
You
see that in there.
Good.
CNPs.
CNP, CNPs.
The range. Oh, wonderful. How about we just,
you know, nuke that? Nobody needs a net
limit range. Called unlimited, though. Clearly, that's a
good one.
Unlimited.
Look at it. Oh, thank you. You guys
are so wonderful.
I can't believe the name lies. It was
more than that.
Wow. Two level ranges and two clusters.
No.
That's
Webhooks.
Webhooks. Yeah.
None of those.
Resource quotas net polls. K.
That's all looking
all the pods are running.
So
Yeah. Let's check the services,
objects too in the default namespace.
I also saw
something interesting,
like, the port is six six seven instead
of six six six.
Better than that.
Table. Must have been accidental.
Yes.
K.
So we know that's Let's confirm that,
yeah, let's first let's first confirm that our
deployment is listening on 666.
Yeah. It should be the same one as
Normally, but who knows what Zapier team prepared
us.
Yeah. It it is there.
Should we update it?
Let's change this. Yeah. The server should be
666.
But it's confirmed it is listening on 666
inside of the
pod.
K.
So
that part should be looking good. Now let's
see.
Okay. So the last thing we got, though,
was failed to connect database. So there might
be some
interesting
name or not known. Okay. Well,
let's then get our deployment
and look at that and see what our
DNS config is.
Edit this so people can
scroll with me here.
That's her first. Okay.
Might as well change the we
might as well change the image while we're
at it.
Here's that image. I just wanna avoid DNS
entirely.
Do you know remember what the the other
values are
for this so we don't have to use
cluster first? Because, I mean, we can go
look at the the worker node and see
what its DNS policy is set to.
Let me Google it real quick.
K. Just for the records, Rust application
has a hard coded lookup of Postgres.
So a a well a well need cluster
DNS.
K.
So I found a limit in here. We
don't need that.
We have plenty of resources available.
It's the only app on the cluster.
So
let's see.
You know, it's interesting. So not We we
could just look at the
like, what we were messing around with on
the worker.
Check the the cubelets
config.
I'll put this back to your cluster first.
Yeah.
Cluster first with host net is the other
one you were thinking of.
K. But I don't think we need that.
Yep.
Six six six and then next.
K. Build lookup still. So let's go look
at on
this host on these.
It might have messed with config.
Is that a config map here?
Yes.
K. Or at least usually is.
K. So we're seeing
health.
Is that not an r?
Doesn't look like an r, does it?
No. It doesn't.
Let's go play with that.
That's
fun little typo. That's breaking an unofficial custard
rule of no unique with characters.
Naughty naughty team. Naughty team.
K. Forwarding that to resolve conf as it's
upstream.
I don't know if this Prometheus is necessary
in here. There's obviously not on this cluster,
but that might just be something default. I
don't think it should mess with the filter
pane of.
So let's
let's do that. And I know that will
live reload, but
And we should also check the
the result comp file.
Yes.
That is very polite using a rollout restart.
That is five years of
a whole lot of other tenants on our
clusters. Could have at least added a wee
message just to log why you were restarting
it as well.
Yeah. If you don't know, at Adobe, Kubernetes,
we are a we're ethos team. We are
a platform team for all of Adobe.
So we
there are certain things that are baked into
our how we do things.
I I think those are good good things
to be baked in.
So I'm gonna go actually, we can
we can just do this from local hosts.
Yeah. We're still getting DNS issues.
Okay.
So
DNS. It's the wonderful thing that it's gonna
be broken even when you don't think it's
broken.
So let's go look at
let's look at ic.com on this host.
K. It says pointing to resolve
the
DNS server,
a 14775
address.
David, what is DNS supposed to be set
to on these hosts?
That is an Equinix IP, so I think
they're okay.
out of this? Yes.
Let's check the
Let's check the bar list.
is an Equinix IP, which will be the
which as the region for this cluster, you'll
be hitting our local DNS server.
Yeah. Okay. So 14775
is
At farlibkubeletconfig.
Look at it.
Yeah. There's some interest in DNS settings on
there. That's a good idea.
That should be config.YAML,
I believe.
That's
126010?
That is correct.
Then what's the service? Is the service set
to that?
The
you're saying the Kate service?
Yeah.
So, yeah, so the it is set to
that. I confirmed it just above system.
Okay. Can we
hop over to one of the workers?
Actually, I wanna look at that file.
Me look at that
search
object really quick just to make sure nothing
is messed up in there. I have also
opened a session on Zapier worker one if
you wanna join that session too.
Yeah. While Jake's looking at the other thing,
I'll hop over to that and
Zapier worker
one.
K. I'm I'm just going to exec into
just describe what I'm doing. I'm gonna exec
into the pod and try DNS queries and
see what happens.
The cluster DNS in the config is fine,
but
there is that live reload that could happen
with the config file on cluster.
You can do an app install DNS utils,
I think, if you need access to take
I was I wasn't I was actually just
gonna skip it because curl did it correctly.
But what we should do is dig postgres.
What is the It doesn't resolve.
Yeah. What is it supposed to be, though?
Postgres
dot
default DotService dot Cluster dot local.
K. So
Does it work for Kubernetes?
If you dig against the
I mean, if you do it yeah. If
you jump back into that container and try
to get the Kubernetes.default.service
dot local, does that resolve?
And use
Cluster Never remember what the actual DNS name
is, so I'm not positive. Actually If cluster
dot local.
Oh, okay. Sorry. The
I mean, n dot should mean oh, service
dot customer dot local. But you should be
able to detect Kubernetes on this one as
well.
Yeah. So it's it's not resolved. I'm wondering
I'm wondering if they
removed in the cluster the Kubernetes config if
they removed the service
pieces.
We got eight minutes.
It got changed back.
What's up with that?
That's interesting.
That's sneaky.
They're keeping you back. A a job or
a cron job. So
Yeah. That
was a bit fast to a cron job,
but maybe.
K. None of those. But what we can
do is just reconfigure it, create our own
config map.
That's all of that. Or maybe there is
a a crumbly a crumbly job running at
the. There
definitely could be a crumb job on the
host itself, but we only have seven minutes.
So I'm just going to copy this really
quick.
Let's see. I need to be able to
create
Okay. So I can
the profile look okay?
Just
It does. You fixed the r? I need
to change I need to change the name
to something else.
It was there.
It's better to deploy.
Using the IP seems to be working.
Maybe it's just a DNS now.
Where is my volume?
Oh, terminal is getting messed up.
Where's the volume
from config map there?
K.
Let's see what you got.
Hey. Hey, Rawkode.
Yeah. It's working. Up your limits.
Is that what we needed?
I believe so. I'm gonna try and have
it anyway. So
Yeah. It looks working.
You got the Thanos. Hey.
Welcome to the one. That's awesome.
Well Well done. Your team. I don't know
what was changing that.
I don't know what was changing that the
DreamUp file.
So was fun.
Well, we never change our current jobs on
the host,
and
I guess that could have been one way.
Yeah.
If it changes so fast, there's something I
think it was something in cluster.
I I'm not sure.
I'm not sure what. Maybe they'll drop it
into the comments. Not in Missouri.
But nice work. Yeah. I'm looking forward to
seeing what they post and send for the
Yeah. Oh, cloud custodian. Cloud custodian.
Alright.
Alright. Well, this is a lot of fun.
Yeah.
Yeah. That was fun. Those were two pretty
pretty mean clusters, but you both absolutely smashed
it. So well done, both teams. That was
a that was great work.
And so Yeah. Thank you to Zapier team
as well. Well done.
Alright.
Very well done.
Well, thank you for joining me. I'll let
you skip back to your day, and we're
gonna draw some banners for t shirts. You're
welcome to to hang around if you want,
or you can, you know, watch on the
YouTube. It's up to you. But we've got
let me get my
oh, come on, Internet. You've been fine all
day. There we go.
Now my internet is going terribly.
Alright. Let's share my screen.
So this is today's competition. We'll draw the
two winners.
Come on. Let's go.
Kevin and Avanash.
So you're both in the Discord. So just
send me a DM and we'll get you
sorted out with those t shirts.
We've got one more from last week that
I forgot because it was a weird epic
two and a half hour
cluster. And I'm never doing a community one
again as much as you may want me
to.
And last week's winners are
Jeff and Jason. Okay. I'm not sure if
you are on the Discord, but DM me
on Twitter,
YouTube comments, however you want. Just get in
touch with me, give me your details, and
I'll get you the t shirt. And that's
us. Thank you to team Zapier, Zapier,
and team Adobe. Thank you to Equinix Medal
and Teleport for continuing to sponsor this. And
John,
you cannot get a t shirt for suffering
on cost of I'll tell you what, if
you join me again, I'll I'll definitely get
you a t shirt. Alright. Thanks to everyone
in the comments. It's been an absolute pleasure.
I will see you all
for the next episode, which will be just
after KubeCon. So we won't have one next
week because of DevOpsDave Birmingham and I'm on
I'll be away at the conference pretending that
it's 2019 again. Have a wonderful day and
I'll see you all soon. Adios.